[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette deuxième partie de
notre jt nous allons maintenant
retourner sur le terrain avec spécial
grains qui est présente aujourd'hui
devant l'organisation météorologique
mondiale à genève où les scientifiques
du giec viennent à nouveau de donner la
vie c'était si pourriez vous nous
expliquer la situation
bien sûr karens et le processus de
gestation le plus complexes au monde qui
vient de s'achever quatre ans c'est le
temps qu'il aura fallu aux quelques deux
mille experts scientifiques mandatés par
les 195 pays membres du giec pour
synthétiser pas moins de quatorze mille
articles scientifiques
les conclusions sont très claires les
êtres humains ou absolument tout
retourné sur notre planète et pour ceux
qui en doutaient encore nous sommes
désormais fixé 100 % du changement
climatique est dû aux activités humaines
le reste des 4000 pages de ce rapport
est tout aussi éclairant sur l'état des
écosystèmes et nous devons maintenant
nous saisir de l'urgence nous devons
faire de ce sujet notre priorité mais
attendez un instant on me dit dans
l'oreillette qu'on va malheureusement
devoir interrompre ce reportage pour
parler d'un événement extraordinaire en
événements pardon qui va probablement
bouleverser vos vie chamboulée la
surface de notre planète même altérer le
sens de rotation de notre terre le
messie est arrivé
enfin je voulais dire le messie
en quelques minutes je viens de vous
démontrer quelque chose qui s'est passé
pour de vrai dans nos médias le rapport
du giec est une référence absolue sur
l'état des connaissances autour du
changement climatique a été balayé en
quelques heures en une journée de nos
médias au profit d'une actualité
instantané
qui a été tout simplement jugé plus
accrocheuses plus vendeurs en gros ça
faisait des like quoi
ça c'est un petit peu dommage et on est
assez déçu notre cher chirac avait donc
bien raison de nous dire que notre
maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs
se cherche irak toujours le mot juste
cela nous amène donc aussi j'ai même de
ce thé dicks le rôle de l'information et
du journalisme dont vous l'aurez compris
la transition écologique
peut-être pour commencer soyons tous
d'accord sur un terme l'information
qu'est ce qu'une information aidant il
s'agit d'une connaissance qui va suivre
plusieurs étapes d'abord elle est rendue
accessible par un support un article ou
une vidéo par exemple
ensuite elle va être communiqués ou plus
communément diffusé par des canaux de
communication à des individus des
citoyens comme vous et moi ou des
décideurs comme notre président de la
république
emmanuel macron dans l'objectif de
déclencher une réaction une action dans
le cas que j'ai déclenché en
introduction je vous ai présenté avec
tout l'humour que je pouvais vous donner
on avait un des connaissances
disponibles dans nos quatorze mille
articles scientifiques qui ont été
rassemblés dans le rapport du giec puis
c'est là que ça commence à coincer le
moment de la communication
aujourd'hui on a deux moyens de
communication qui s'affrontent ou se
complémentent en fonction de la
situation le premier à l'ère du
numérique et d'internet les réseaux
sociaux le deuxième les médias dits
traditionnels la télé les risques la
radio ou même tout simplement vos
journaux
le problème c'est que aujourd'hui je
vais me fixer uniquement sur le deuxième
réseau les médias dits traditionnels
dans l'exemple que j'ai pu vous donner
en introduction les connaissances
scientifiques qui étaient rendus
disponibles le problème c'est qu'elles
ont été absolument
renverser par cette actualité
alors que l'euro baromètre a montré que
le changement climatique se hisse en
tête des préoccupations des européens
avant le terrorisme seulement 1% des
sujets liés à cette question dans nos
médias le traître réellement dans ce
petit pourcentage que je viens de vous
définir
on retrouve souvent des approximations
sur les faits scientifiques ou encore
des minimisation sur l'urgence
climatique
là ça c'est une de mes deux mais une
préférée ça vient du point il s'intitule
climat ne croyez pas les alarmistes
la deuxième favorite valeurs actuelles
il nous dit les charlatans de l'écologie
avec notre grippe attenberg
internationale
pourtant si les médias ont carrément
foire et leur mission huit français sur
dix estiment que la médiatisation des
enjeux environnementaux et climatiques
induit une prise de conscience on
intérêt accru mais aussi une
modification des comportements
absolument tout ce dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui
la triste vérité c'est que comme je
viens de vous le détailler à ces
informations elles n'arriveront que très
rarement entre vos mains si vous n'aviez
pas assister à ces dicks peut-être que
vous n'auriez jamais entendu parler de
vieques de ce rapport et même de son
contenu
sans pouvoir nous atteindre
l'information ne se transformera jamais
en actions
alors même qu'une action n'existe en
pratique que par l'action qu'elle va
justement suscité
concrètement c'est parce que nos
politiques publiques doivent être
éclairées par la science que ces
scientifiques se sont réunis autour
d'une table pour nous donner le rapport
du giec à ce qu'on va être très clair on
se lance pas dans la rédaction de 4000
pages sur le changement climatique pour
s'en servir de livres de chevet
vraiment pas
mais tout n'est pas joué j'avoue que
j'ai été un petit peu pessimiste et que
vous avez sûrement des idées noires à
l'instant même où je parle mais tout
n'est pas joué on peut encore faire
dévier l'histoire et c'est pour ça que
beaucoup de personnes nous disent
qu'aujourd'hui on est peut-être la
dernière génération à pouvoir encore
agir sur les documents
dans ce combat il s'agit désormais pour
les médias de travailler sur cette étape
de communication que je vous ai décrites
comme assez assez rouillé aujourd'hui
parce que ouais il y aura toujours une
nouvelle news apparaissant de nulle part
le lancement de la 20 g pour vous
permettre de regarder votre prono en 25
secondes
un milliardaire bien décidé à conquérir
l'univers même une énième personnes se
sentant investis par le devoir d'être
candidate à la présidentielle
mais si une issue de ces événements est
assez incertaine il ya une histoire
qu'on sait d'ores et déjà qu'elle se
termine mal et c'est celle de la
dégradation des conditions de vie sur
terre
vous ne l'avez peut-être pas entendu à
la télé ou lu dans votre quotidien
préféré
mais en 50 ans deux tiers de la fin de
sauvage a disparu deux tiers si on fait
rien on pourrait se dire que peut-être
un jour on pourra bientôt par les deux
derniers hommes sur terre
remarquerez que j'ai bien parlé du
dernier homme sur terre parce
qu'aujourd'hui la dernière femme ça
ressemble plutôt à un
moins flatteur
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais m'adresser
à vous messieurs dames les journalistes
et milliardaire détenteurs de nos médias
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas être sérieux
cinq minutes face à une crise qui
guettent l'humanité le journalisme et
les médias avec le rôle d'information
ont un rôle essentiel à jouer dans la
prise de conscience collective sur les
enjeux mais également sur les solutions
qui s'offrent à nous
l'histoire l'a bien montré la
communication est un outil hyperpuissant
on peut se souvenir d'ailleurs de
l'article j'accuse d'emile zola
mon corps de l'appel du 18 juin 1940 qui
a pu résonner dans les foyers grâce à la
radio c'est ce rôle fédérateur et
mobilisateur que doivent retrouver nos
médias aujourd'hui
et dans la transition écologique on a
une chance c'est qu'on connaît déjà les
solutions à 24 ans seulement je viens de
vous décrire ce qui commence à clocher
dans nos médias et qui a cloché depuis
un petit moment aujourd'hui
mois grand manitou des médias
j'arrêterai d'offrir une tribune aux
climato-sceptiques qui devraient
retrouver leur place aux côtés des
plates east des adorateurs de la
croissance infinie
mois grand manitou des médias je
traiterai la question climatique comme
l'urgence calais en lui offrant une
vraie couverture médiatique parce que
ouais pas de panique en lui dédiant ne
serait ce que 10 à 15% de nos sujets on
pourra toujours parler d'insécurité
d'islamo gauchy six
mois grand manitou des médias je
donnerai la parole aux scientifiques
ceux qui détiennent le savoir plutôt
qu'à des polémistes qui après une balade
au bois de vincennes et l'écoutent d'un
podcast sur la croissance verte se sont
dit ça y est gage vais parler de climat
d'un peu trop de confiance
moi grand manitou des médias
j'arrêterai d'applaudir les rois de la
politique des petits pas et les
représentants de greenwashing
corporation venu nous présenter leurs
dernières innovations
tension vous êtes prêts le sac à dos
purificateurs d'air créé 100 % à partir
de concombres recyclés en fait
aujourd'hui
bref et je suis assez confiante
aujourd'hui que j'ai très peu de chances
de devenir grand manitou des médias
premièrement parce que
j'ai un prêt étudiant à rembourser que
j'ai à peu près dix balles sur mon
compte en banque
la deuxième raison c'est que je suis une
femme et je sais pas si vous avez
regardé un jour qui est à la tête de nos
médias aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'il
faille être bien équipé pour être à la
tête du monde
oui
alors outre tout ses blagues et toute
l'énergie que j'ai pu mettre dont
s'était dit que il ya une chose que
j'aimerais que vous reteniez aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a les médias qu'on mérite et
les médias qui nous ressemble alors on
va devoir changer si on veut qu'ils
changent et surtout peut-être que demain
mais si lui aussi nous parlera de climat
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]